what's up bleep nation greetings from
London England it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves and I
want something like to rub off on you so
you can go off and do amazing things to
change the planet and so in this video
I'm doing a highlight reel the best of
videos from different entrepreneur
channels these are friends of Mines that
people who are also creating great
content to help you guys as
entrepreneurs maybe you've seen their
channels maybe you've never heard of
them before this is my favorites from
the past month that they put out and if
you want to check them out folder you
can go to look at the links in the
description below enjoy guys
and I need you to be very honest about
where you are in terms of what you're
trying to do like where are you so for
those of you who like I want to be a
millionaire I just need you to really be
like think through where are you
financially like in terms of financial
literacy where are you in terms of
financial discipline where are you and
in your past where are you do you spend
money you don't have
so I heard somebody said he said today I
thought it was fun right
somebody was talking about and at this
time time I'm in town and you try to
hear me can you can you lift your own
weight right can you lift your own
weight so somebody would say like yo I
don't know why you're all on the phone
all proud of the fact that you could
change your own oil like why would you
want to change your own oil anywhere
that's not your job right and somebody
was like well I saved 140 dollars he
like save 140 dollars but what have you
made 250 dollars an hour no hear what
I'm saying why would you change your own
oil to save 140 dollars when it took you
three hours to do it
and somebody like yo so you said you
always I said look let me jump in like I
ain't trying to be disrespectful but
first of all I didn't go to school to
change oil that ain't my job that's
somebody's job let my man do his job
somebody else said that when he changed
your oil because he went to school
there's some other stuff under the
engine that he's see that you don't see
when you change the oil so y-you saved
140 dollars you missed something else
that he would've helped you catch so
that the life of your car so you changed
your oil but you didn't notice the three
or four the things that was missing
I said look let's not talk about you
saving 140 here's the challenge you
can't pull your own weight the challenge
is you shouldn't have a car that costs
you a hundred and forty dollars change
the oil when you ain't got 104 thousand
change or
you should have that car in the first
place why do you have a vehicle than 200
cause 140 and you can't afford it why
would you buy something that you got to
change the oil that's not your job and
you know why you're doing it because
it's no longer a car to you - a status
symbol and so we deal it with something
deeper you can't hold your own way you
bought something you can't afford why
the deeper issues because you got a
self-esteem problem and so you got
shortcuts so you drive a car to make it
look like you somewhere you are but when
you actually there you ain't gotta have
a car that look like you there cuz
you're there no hear what I just said
when you're there you don't have to look
like you there cuz you there but when
you're not there you can't pick your own
weight up you have to do stuff and now
you didn't messed up your whole credit
because you bought a car so that people
can think in somewhere that you not and
you've destroyed your whole future then
if you could hold your own way you could
drive around the Ford Fusion in some
tombow come like like a ranger you
getting out that joint like a Range
Rover you getting out the Ford Fusion
like what like you in a 7:45 a lot like
what why because you ready
are you here are you ready
people look for the shortcut the hack
the shortcut is a lie the hack doesn't
get you there there is no easy way there
is only discipline
can't control other people the only
person you can control is you you have
control over your mind I'm nothing but
weakness I get
stupid things I eat the raw
don't sleep enough i procrastinate I
waste time I care too much about stupid
things and
in all those ways I am weak but I don't
accept that
here's something that's important to
relate to children that you are not your
accomplishments you are you in the only
way you are going to get better at
accomplishing things is to be a hundred
percent honest about the amount of
effort you put in and what the actual
result of that effort is whether it's a
failure or a success that does not
define you that defines your
participation in this particular
activity it is not you you are an
individual that will hopefully learn
from all of your endeavors but you're
never gonna learn if you lie to yourself
you're never gonna learn but if somebody
makes this nobody scores a point and
there are no winners and there are no
losers and everybody's amazing that's
not good because voice by the way it's
not good because there's going to be
people out there that are driven in
psychotic and they're gonna get ahead
there's people that are task oriented
and goal oriented and they they have an
idea ahead of them gonna try to figure
out how to make this happen they have a
goal they want to reach it and if you're
competing with that person in any form
of life and they're not burdened down by
the [ __ ] that we give so many kids
today they're gonna have a massive
advantage and this idea that this kid
who's been coddled and treated like he's
always gonna be a winner that somehow or
another they're gonna be happier is
Creina
you know I think about the business as
the horse and I think as the CEO as the
jockey
I always if it's 50/50 lean towards the
person because some of the biggest
business Nintendo started as a playing
card company and it was the
entrepreneurs that ran that business
that kept changing the business you know
when I started vaynermedia I didn't
think it would be what it is today I
never thought it would be what it is
today I thought it was gonna be
something different so great
entrepreneurship is not being romantic
about what you started out to do
it's about adjusting to the reality of
what your business has to do and so I
never have invested I that's not true
there have been times that I'd become so
infatuated with the person that I met
that I invested even though I didn't
believe in their idea because I wanted
to build a relationship with them and I
thought to myself even if I lose this
twenty five or fifty thousand dollars in
the second or third business that she or
he builds she'll be successful and I'll
be there to be a part of it but far more
often I have to believe in your idea and
believe that you have the stomach my
biggest fear with your generation of
entrepreneurship is that
entrepreneurship is now cool and that
you're doing it because of either money
or coolness not because you can't
breathe without it and I'm looking for
entrepreneurs that can't breathe and
ever if you if you think in your mind
right now it'll be really cool to try a
business but if it doesn't work I'll go
into banking I don't want to invest in
you
but I think it's it's powerful because I
think most people aren't willing to
reinvent we were doing the internet
marketing spammy thing for a little bit
and if you kept doing that you would
have probably dropped off - yeah but you
found a way to reinvent with blogging
yeah and you stuck with that until you
realize oh let me do the next stage yeah
right yeah I think that's always
important I was kind of a similar spot I
was starting out in blogging I was
teaching LinkedIn and I yeah like it's
kind of dying and I do blogging courses
and I was like I feel like podcasting
was gonna come around I was like
hopefully you know you're in the right
space now maybe it was it was like two
years before kind of started getting big
when a cereal came out and everyone else
started to do them mm-hmm so I was like
thank goodness I started early yeah but
um it's almost like now there's you know
over half a million podcasts at least
yeah it's like what's the next
reinvention yeah I'm always looking for
the next reinvention
never get your financial advice from a
millionaire stop thinking like a
middle-class loser folks the
middle-class is a losing situation I
know people hate this message it is not
popular I'm gonna keep telling you until
you finally come around to what I know
the middle-class is based on scarcity
million dollars a million dollars today
is the new middle class let's say you
can't make any money for the next 30
years let's just assume because you said
a million dollars is a bunch of money
not if you don't have more money coming
in so if I stop the drip coming in if I
stop the income because the millionaire
next door said income is not a way to
get rich that's not true
income is the way to stay rich you can't
get rich without income and you can't
stay rich without income the problem
with money is time right so if you have
a million dollars and you only have one
day left to live to you rich you
understand what I'm saying money is is
basically a measurement of time think
big do not get your advice from little
thinkers why would you be a millionaire
when you could be a hundred million do
the math man what's the real number who
wants one of anything the number one is
a week number it's the zeros that are
power get you a bunch of zeros and then
add any number to
I was a fool in my 20s I was such I had
such low self-esteem and I was trying to
find my way just as all 20 euros or
Howell do I'm gonna be 20 you're gonna
be Toya yeah
you're not even 20 no and I answered
okay so this is the thing I would say to
experience the 20s as an adventure in
learning about yourself it really is the
opportunity where you get to discover
who you are what you want to do what
your passion where your passion lies
you're supposed to do things figure out
this doesn't really feel like where I'm
supposed to be in my life and then move
on
listening to your instincts is really
key in your 20s so that you don't mess
yourself up you know for really truly I
did all my awful stuff including drugs
and wrong men and holding on to bumpers
and don't lay it's about discovering who
you are and not giving over your power
to someone else and believing that
anybody else defines your life
how can I learn to feel good about the
work that I create ah if I could answer
this definitively I would be a very
wealthy man
yeah I would have moved out a lot of
pain for a lot of people over centuries
so let me let me ask you a couple of
follow-up question here so presumably
you're saying like you make something
and then a little bit later you look at
you're like oh my god what was I
thinking is that a is that a common
theme yeah um a lot of times for me at
least it happened in the process of a
project got it
all right so there's I got two two
directions I want to take this first of
all there's this arc of a project like
this is a great idea and then the next
step is I'm not quite so sure about this
and the next one is oh my god this great
idea sucks and then it's I suck and then
you put a little you keep putting the
effort in and you're like wait a minute
I can see the light in a title
everything's gonna be okay oh my god
I'm okay and this piece of work is
pretty good and no it's no notice it's
not like well and if it does not good
then you're like not just pretty good
then oh my god this is awesome I'm so
glad I pushed through so on each sort of
project level and I think you know James
victori has talked a lot about this he's
a famous designer and if you know him or
not
there's this Oh Austin Kleon you know
the guy who wrote show your work and
what else did he write show your work
and steal like an artist those are two
really great books if you haven't
checked that out but he's got a really
funny graph that that sort of covers
this the emotional arc that creators go
through on any individual project so I
want you to check check out Austin and I
think I'm kind of paraphrasing that
little that journey but so while you're
in the process that is part of the
process and I would also say that if you
don't get into something where you're
annoyed at the details and they're
frustrating and painful then you really
haven't gotten into it and if you're
just sort of glancing on the surface
you're bouncing across
the surface then you're probably not
getting into it enough to make something
that's amazing and so I would say try
and try and get used to that arc on
every project I don't think it ever goes
away if you're putting as much effort
into it as you should so that's one one
thing that I want you to pay attention
to and again it gave you a couple
resources there so in this video of
course yes you're going to learn how to
win an argument but you're also going to
learn how to get what it is that you
actually want from the argument you're
going to learn how to make it so that
the relationship is strengthened after
it and not ruined even if you do wind up
getting what you want so the first thing
is this we want to redefine what winning
means because sadly too many of us what
winning an argument means is the other
guy
losing we want them to admit that their
opinion is wrong we want the people
around who are watching us argue to say
you have a really good appointment
they're out of their mind but the truth
is say that you're arguing about chores
and you want the other person to do more
chores and everybody at the end of it
comes up to you and says you were right
you won they lost well guess what that
doesn't feel very good
1 & 2 they're still not doing what you
want them to do which is to help out
more around the house so redefine what a
win is what is it that you actually want
to change from this discussion and I
will shift it from an argument to a
discussion so if you want the person to
do chores okay start there if you're in
a legal or a business setting and you
want more money more favorable contract
terms start there
forget sticking it to do them or
teaching them a lesson or showing them
how silly they are when those are your
motivators everybody loses but when you
focus on the things that you want you
are much more likely to communicate in a
way that gets them
a poor man with confidence it's
unstoppable I love that quote I love the
message and I agree the next question
then becomes well how do you get that
confidence if you're in a bad
environment if you're poor if you don't
have great people around you how do you
get that confidence and some people may
be born with it I don't know for me it
was much more about changing my
environment and so I got confident some
of it from my parents believed came from
them they always told me I was Evan
Casserly Carmichael I could do whatever
I wanted and that gave me a sense of
confidence but if I looked that into my
entrepreneurial career a lot of it came
from my habits and in what I was reading
and now later into the videos by
surrounding myself with people that are
confident they're doing big things not
necessarily in my actual life you know I
don't have a ton of super successful
super confident friends that I hang
around with it's much more from
aspirational mentors and I created the
YouTube channel in part selfishly for
myself the top ten rules sell that you
for myself to be around greatness to be
around success on a regular basis and
you could do that for yourself as well
if you want to develop confidence it may
come by watching videos on seven ways to
get more confidence or reading books on
how to be more confident kind of those
tactical how to's but I think a lot of
it also comes from just the environment
just from osmosis just by being around
confident people and some of that wears
off on you right it's why I started to
mentor me series let's hang on people
been a lot more than us and some of
their mindsets and their beliefs and the
way that they think about things seeps
into us to help us become the best
version of ourselves not to be the next
Elon Musk's or Steve Jobs or whoever but
the more confident better version of
ourselves and there was a point where it
really struck me where I was driving
with my father in the car and I just
signed a deal with Stephen Kelly was the
CEO of sage and he runs you know
multi-billion dollar company with you
know 10 to 15 thousand employees and
we're both doing these QA we're
answering questions I'm hosting the show
we get a question from an entrepreneur
he answers that I answer it and my dad
ask me how do you get the confidence to
be on par with Stephen Kelly that that
you know you're his equal that you're
answering questions alongside him it
wasn't in a you sock kind of town it was
at a general admiration like where did
that come from like that's amazing the
supportive way and I thought about and
it's really from the videos you know
it's really from all this work because
I'm hanging around
it's Elon Musk in Kanye West and Snoop
Dogg you know and Martha Stewart and all
of these successful people whether
they're athletes or musicians or
entrepreneurs I'm around that constantly
and so seeing people being confident and
going off and doing great things makes
me be more confident and so by hanging
around greatness more you unleash a
little bit more greatness inside of
yourself as well and the more you do
that and the more consistent you are
with that then the more is going to come
out so I agree that a poor man with
confidence will be unstoppable
the question that becomes how do you get
that confidence and if you weren't born
with it I think that's okay I think
there's so much you can do by changing
your habits by changing your environment
by surrounding yourself with maybe not
people like you may not have people
around you but by resources information
videos guides of confident successful
people that will unleash that inner
boldness and you to go off and do
amazing things so thank you guys so much
for watching hope you enjoyed I'd love
to know which one was your favorite
which clip you learn the most term that
you're gonna apply immediately
how to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below thank
you again we believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
from London we'll see you soon